yeah well those Christmas reviews were
fun them it's time to make way for the
future and empty that cave there we go
now on to Rachel's farewell video
what the hell oh that's right I left all
the footage for her farewell video in
the Christmas folder I'm a Kris yes you
want me to do what fly back from
California so we can shoot your farewell
video would get critic I can't fly all
the way out there and shoot that in such
a short amount of time okay look I know
a lot of opportunities have opened up
for you down there I'm simply asking you
to throw away your future for my
personal needs I can't do it there's no
time but it was such a good idea it
won't take long to shoot you died during
a war by having your head to capitate
before falling down an elevator shaft
after being spit out by a gooey alien
while getting in a car accident during
the red wedding it ain't happening oh
come on what am I supposed to do have
Malcolm and I discover a video message
left here by Rachel
[Music]
hello critic hello Malcolm by the time
you see this I will be in California
some opportunities I've opened up to how
we continue my career as an actress the
one door is closed I will never forget
the good times we've had the fun the
last the fact that Malcolm's Lord bore
women's clothing than I have oh thanks I
remember it all finally you guys are
amazing friends and I will never forget
the good times we've had together thank
you so much for letting me be a part of
this experience and if I should die
during the war by having my head
decapitated before falling down an
elevator shaft after being spit out by a
gooey alien while getting in a car
accident during the red wedding don't be
shocked well you won't well that's not
let this ruin Nicolas Cage month I
wasn't planning to
okay Nicolas Cage
[Applause]
[Music]
ha ha Brees love the movie I was in his
whole ghostwriter and I played man
I was really excited now I really think
I got it through the busy
[Applause]
[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to and
welcome to Nicolas Cage money
oh you bizarre human explosion of a man
just how did you get such a following
the past five years or so I mean don't
get me wrong
Nicolas Cage has been a Hollywood star
for some time now he's even gotten a lot
of credit as a pretty good actor but
with the birth of the internet people
start to notice compilation videos that
showcased a certain motif if you will
that means that Nicolas Cage likes to
act nuts
the Nicolas Cage freak out that's
practically patented itself because
nobody else can possibly duplicate it
it's his own strange concoction of 10%
off work yelling 10% over the tops
passing 20% creepy smiling and an
astonishing 60 percent out of skull eye
Balaji making for the delightful protein
shake that is our Nicolas Cage so okay
we all know that he can make any premise
interesting by his insane performances
but what happens when you take an
over-the-top actor mix him with another
over-the-top actor and combine them
together with the most over-the-top
director of all frigging time you get a
mushroom cloud of uneasiness and
awkwardness simply known as facial
[Music]
as if the in-your-face acting style
Nicolas Cage wasn't enough we're
complemented with multi Razzie Award
winner John Travolta together with
director and professional dull fetishist
John Woo for literally the most
overblown action flick sense
well okay John who's next overblown
action flick but no no I have one crazy
ego to deal with and this one has two
and every moment of screen time is
delicious 90s cornball perfection so
let's go eat a peach for hours this is
face so it's the credits roll we see
John Travolta as a cop named Sean Archer
who's with his son in one of the most
wonderful places anyone could be in the
90s flashback laughs yeah you know this
place were mundane activities that could
be considered serviceable at best are
suddenly romanticized with constant
slo-mo laughing kissing this weird thing
that'd be annoying if you did it in real
life
everything average is made great a
flashback land if I was to ask someone
for a snack you'd be like hey guy who
gummi bear sure not very exciting but in
flashback lands
[Music]
well I should quit while I was ahead
that's not should a Travolta for that
matter as his nemesis a terrorist for
higher name castor Troy played by cage
tries to shoot Archer but kills his son
instead
oh come on Chum no doves that was at
least three doves worthy how do we know
you want us to feel something if you
don't have dogs
[Music]
now to this film's credit this is a
pretty dramatic and emotional scene but
it does kind of beg the question why
does Cage stop shooting he's got him
right there what's stopping him
doesn't he know where the flash for days
can become the cliched obsessed cop that
every 80s and 90s movie has ever given
us well seeing only missed the first
time maybe we just draw the conclusion
that cage is a terrible shot so here's
pass and like I said Sean Archer becomes
the stereotypical crazy obsessed cop
we're a covert anti-terrorist eeeem that
is so secret when we put this thing to
bed you can brand the Fourth Amendment
on my butt we'll take a break when the
case breaks while you were still
learning to spell your name I was being
trained to hunt actors from the Clunes
we also see cage smoking around heavy
explosives that's smart as to this
film's credit it does give him the most
fitting intro music and over-the-top
Cage performance should be given I will
make a petition to make sure that every
cage introduction plays that music and I
think we see the typical way Cage most
likely keeps only the seven
you hand over hassled
[Music]
[Applause]
you know I think the only reason cage
hasn't done a 3d movie is because the
audience is afraid he'll come out and
eat them I know it's a long shot but I'm
not taking the risk so the bomb is said
in cage makes his way to head out the
country I'm just showing off how cool my
cape would have been if I was Superman
come on guys it could've worked but stay
away from downtown on the 18th it's
gonna be a little smoky
wasn't that the tagline for Hobbit too
but team Travolta is hot on his trail is
determined to not let him take off I
can't believe they located my personal
jet and expensive rent-a-car I'm
supposed to be the most secretive
terrorist ever an undercover agent tries
to stop them but gets caught so key
truely's are overdue
[Music]
oh my god buddy every movement you have
is like the ending of some psychotic
Looney Tunes cartoon
[Music]
we will make you do Ghost Rider three
come on guys a piss fire in the last one
even I thought that was kind of stupid
fireworks on the window what's with all
the sparks
I'm telling you I will give that
petition shut the up you watch your
mouth Johnny I think you better
pull the trigger because I don't give a
you know I think Joe who just
always went with the rehearsal take you
know the one that actors do when they
think the camera is off and they're not
really trying
hold on I'm scared I'm ready for the big
good we were rolling oh of course not so
Shawn gets the best of Troy and knocks
him out finally capturing it the team
back at headquarters gives him a
standing ovation but somebody forgot to
tell him he can stop the whole crazy
obsessed cop thing we catches the thing
he was crazily obsessed over where's all
this how about what about to Anderson
Montgomery Berkeley winters
boy who invited Sean Penn to the party
things don't get more chipper when they
find a bomb threat left over by Troy
which is threatening of course to level
the city they tried to get information
off his brother as well it's the rest of
his gang but they don't get anything it
seems like they're running out of
options there is one other possibility
you know instead of saying there's one
other possibility and then driving me
miles away in complete silence why don't
you just tell me what the other
possibility is so turns out Troy is in a
coma and while he's out they said they
can perform a surgery where they rip off
his face and give it to Sean in the
hopes that maybe his brother will tell
him the location of the bomb your blood
types won't match but Pollux won't know
that height difference is negligible use
laser shears for the hairline Micro
plugs the body here we were considering
working on your overacting but you only
enough seem very much to in that area
this is a black-bag operation strictly
off the books
you can't tell Azzaro and you can't tell
your wife and just ahead extra security
to the immediate danger we will add no
extra security to the immediate danger
I'm not even kidding they leave castor
Troy with little to no security watching
him throughout the majority of the film
I can't see that backfiring anytime soon
so this means he has to leave his wife
played by Joan Allen and daughter again
which won't bode well seeing how he's
been so distant for so many years no
you're going back on Simon again there's
one last time I'm not going anywhere
that's what you told me
ah okay it's obvious she's gonna be
upset about this I mean what spouse
wouldn't be but there is a better way to
make her understand the urgency of the
situation just enter into the room and
say oh my god honey there's a bond
there's a bomb is gonna blow up the
entire city everything's gonna die your
daughter's die I'm gonna die wrong in
the thymus I do something well then do
something you said it not me so
operation kabuki actor swap begins
they put Travolta's face in a neon fish
tank for some reason and replace it with
cages monk so the face is set the voice
has changed and he sent to the most
maximum the high-tech SuperDuper secret
is is this prison that no taxpayer would
ever pay this much money for yeah
Guantanamo is a fenced in piece of
but this place is Super Mario brother
foods that can keep a person still any
time that they want oh and just to make
things even better how do they track
these dangerous people with the most
secretive high-tech of devices by purple
dots thinking does that work
what's that verbal time Julian's walking
us to that purple dot and what's that
perfect at doing it's walking next to
that purple dot and what's that purple
dye do it's just standing next to that
purple dodge that purple dot that purple
dot where are these purple dots up to I
don't know sir they're purple dyes my
god perp attacks
so Archer as Troy approaches his brother
but he gets into a fight with a guy who
claims he slept with his wife and sister
this leads me to one of my favorite
concepts in any Nicolas Cage movie
Nicolas Cage trying to be Nicolas Cage
[Applause]
oh my god the ham levels are reaching
maximum people I swear if he keeps going
like this we're gonna reach report point
come down I stopped the fights only I
keep the total lack of control in this
incredibly disciplined and advanced
prison things seem to be going well when
he convinces his brother that he's Troy
and reveals the location of the bomb
it's a work of art belongs there I guess
the only a convention center will have
to do hey thanks seem to be on the
up-and-up
what could possibly go wrong whoops
[Music]
cage often awakens to the mating call of
a peacock
they took switch why but it's cool we're
gonna deal with it and usually followed
by the orgasm of a humpback dolphin and
though you shouldn't be disturbed that
you're by no means surprised by this
what's this about dr. Sol cage again
with no security whatsoever wakes up
from his coma
what's up the doctor and of course all
the people involved and forces them to
give him the exact same operation
meaning quite possibly one of the
greatest combinations of all time over
actor John Travolta now has to Oliver
act like over actor Nicolas Cage okay
okay just give me a minute okay go wait
you get licking see anything you like I
have got to go you're gonna be in here
for the next hundred years oh my god
petroi as Sean reveals that he's killed
all the people who knew about the
operation by claiming they accidentally
tied themselves up doused themselves
with gasoline and set themselves on fire
mr. ace
yeah maybe our visiting room should have
glass to separate people from the
violent criminals but hey what do you
expect from this technologically
advanced super duper secret prison
barely he's had a traumatic childhood
Zenta thank you understood
oh by the way you do a great Nicholas
Cage impression
[Applause]
[Music]
so choice Archer makes a deal with his
brother so that they save the day from
this terrible bomb and Archer as Troy
stays in prison seeing that face on you
makes me afraid my tiramisu might come
back the brains although now I am the
only one with the looks okay did the
brother get is acting lessons from the
aliens and Galaxy Quest my goodness you
exchanged brains as well the other moons
from the Klaatu nebula need your help so
Travolta defuses the bomb which of
course makes him a national hero agent
Archer if the FBI had any leads on who
planted the device
well that is classified information but
if he's listening I wouldn't mind giving
him a message
interception now our sides got the ball
I'm sorry
you sure Jim Carrey didn't steal that
face now our sides got the ball I'm
sorry
take care bye-bye then to make things
better not only is he suave as hell
around the office now but he's also a
ten times better husband and father to
his wife and kid yeah I'm kidding
he teaches his kids self-defense he
makes dinner by candlelight for his wife
it's the president oh and your wife on
line two well you tell the president to
hold you sure this isn't the guy we're
supposed to be rooting for
I get the feeling even Joan Allen is on
to him but she doesn't care she hasn't
gotten as much attention in years and
I'm telling him that Sean Archer writes
his own ticket okay hmm
maybe I should call the police to let
him know he's not my husband oh no I'm
his okay I don't care if you're Terry's
you rub my feet like that you can blow
up Hawaii for all I care but caged cage
is not happy and is eager to look for a
way out so it causes a disturbance which
gets him thrown to the electric ish
chair where you makes a plea to the guy
who attacked him the first day he
arrived Bob I didn't touch your wife
and I didn't touch your sister and I on
the same person I know your wife loves
you he's waiting for you
so let's get out of here more brain-dead
Bendu baja from that five-second speech
I guess he suspected that he was an
innocent man in disguise trying to sneak
in to find the location of a bomb but
accidentally got trapped there for the
rest of his days as now trying to set
things right
mojo some words to make him think that
shoot anything that looks like a purple
top
the two guys caused a panic and break
the entire system of this super duper
itec uber secret security prison as cage
gets separated from his helper take
comfort knowing I'm a lousy father and
husband who's about to spread chaos with
my escape causing the death of dozens
which could have been avoided if I just
stayed here he gets to the surface only
to find that the prison is an island far
from land yes and I'm sure nobody on
shore know this is the giant loud
helicopter firing on a man in this
SuperDuper secret I tagged holy
shit-fuck storm prison I think Spy vs
spy gets better high-tech secrets than
you guys so much choice Troy image is to
swim all the way to shore I guess
Aquaman owed him one and he tries
calling his wife but big shock she
doesn't believe it or maybe she does and
she just doesn't care
again that was a pretty good foot rub so
it goes to Troy's old gang who put him
up and start planning the revenge
against not Archer after taking a few
hits of what I can only assume is called
the Robert Downey jr. once we kidnap a
super cop then what I'd like to take his
his face
Oh
we want to take his face yes his face
nose coming off
the face
wait oh wait let me get this clear
face-off face face off face face on face
off face face face face face face face
face now I got it
wave away mermaid face totally lost he
then discovers that not only does he
have a girlfriend but a son too oh I
want you to meet your father
[Music]
okay so fittingly enough he has a woman
and kid he ignores in this life just as
much as he did in the other one
great minds but Troy is Archer attacks
and tries to take the gang down
but mama Troy doesn't want baby Troy to
be scared so she plays some music for
him which obviously would do
nothing but in a John Woo film
it's about as lame as any other reason
to be artsy someday
where's it
yes and if there's any message that this
movie is trying to get across its don't
put kids in the middle of a violent
shootout between FBI agents and
terrorists for hire I don't know how
many movies we have to make before
America gets that but clearly we're not
there yet come on that was at least five
dumb swarthy five dogs and you didn't
even give us what come on you know
they're all waiting in the back saying
how long we gotta wait back here I don't
know what do you mean you don't know
we're doves in a John Woo movie is like
having man nipples in a sac Schneider
film you just keep quiet what if they
never use us we'll go back to being
standings for that movie no one
remembers but for some reason they're
making a sequel to what Travolta narrows
them down and shoots one of the gang
members in the neck hey man it's some
good times anyway oh yeah I'm sure
that's what he sound like have to be
shot there I think the more appropriate
sound would be like oh so it's the
showdown kinda as Travolta and cage are
back-to-back let's just kill each other
it's symbolic about how they both shot
their own careers another face
[Music]
but cage gets even by acting off
Travolta's brother and thus he finally
gets to his wife and tries to explain
what's going on um nope there's no way I
can't make this awkward so he tells her
to take a blood test in order to find
out the truth she does exactly that as I
guessed Travolta is too manly to not
notice when a needles been stuck in him
and she discovers the truth so now that
he has his wife on his side this now
leads to the real showdown kinda when
Travolta attends the funeral of his boss
who passed away and cage sends a note
and can it be
is it possible that's right because this
is a church that clearly never closes
its door at any time we have religious
symbolic as doves to fill the air but we
need something even more poetically
hardcore for this climax but what do you
say we set those doves on fire at least
he hasn't blowing us up like his
original plan Dominica based videos for
those in service to those to the store
isn't this religious was that to signify
that Travolta is Jesus I mean I know he
believes that but it's too kind
confusing for us so everybody and I mean
everybody comes in to partake in a
Mexican standoff this results in the
girlfriend getting killed the wife
getting away okay and everyone except
our main characters of course getting
xed billing up to the final showdown
gotta all right for all my pointless boy
bout you lawanda Wanda this is a voucher
I have something crazy to tell you I
clearly should have told you this
yesterday so we could bring this to not
such a bloody close but I'm sorry I
needed our foot rub so they make their
way to some boats which of course they
know how to drive they partake in yet
another action see
okay so that's break it off throw in a
few flaming does on that one
[Music]
oh no they must have crashed into two
totally different men driving the same
boats because that quite clearly isn't
Travolta or Kage unless they had another
face operation between those cuts which
given these flat holes wouldn't surprise
sand I can't blow up that so he finally
kills them off the police believe his
story and they take him to get his face
which back his family for some reason
doesn't visit him in the hospital and he
comes home with a brand new mug
yes I have to ask both of you
this is Adam he needs a place to live
Wow really putting us on the spot there
honey
like we're gonna say no straight to a
kid's face who just lost his parents
couldn't we at least have a conversation
about this before yeah I'm still a
terrible husband but what are you gonna
do talk to me
god I miss the other guy
so that's face-off it's over-the-top
ridiculous totally bloated 90s cheese
fun the action is great the acting is
enjoyably corny beyond compare but to
its credit everything is kind of over
the top so it matches the tone it's
silly crazy makes little sense and a
great frigging deal of fun
it only gets sillier and better every
single time I see it
I'm gonna stop sir cricket Nicolas Cage
month has just begun okay those 1/4 worm
a sinner
[Music]
also when matchstick managers for the
Ironman - honestly I think I could have
been a really great Iron Man I was
almost Superman at one point but despite
all my rage I'm still necklace times
okay so this episode is semi based on a
true story Malcolm really was killed by
a gummy bear no this was Rachel's last
episode as she has gone back to
California some opportunities have
opened up for her there but here's the
thing that also it's kind of true is
that actually we did shoot this great
big exit episode that actually did tie
into the review and it was really big
and also introduced the new actress
coming in to take Rachel's place but
sadly the thing that's also true about
it is that it was deleted by yours truly
and I feel awful about that it's one of
the dumbest things I have ever done
and I feel awful about it but we didn't
want people to think Oh Rachel was just
another performer you know came in when
stuff no because she was really really
cool and she was always upbeat always
optimistic no drama whatsoever and was
just even on days when like you could
tell she was really tired and doing a
lot of performing at plays and stuff and
I she always gave me a big smile always
gave it 100% and we chill awesome really
really appreciate that so we got her
here right now say hi Rachel hi like I
said we just wanted to give one last
farewell tour because we did have a
farewell video in what we recorded as
well but like I said deleted dumbass so
we just wanted her here you know just
via Skype to say any last words that you
wanted to get out to the channel awesome
audience yeah all you really want to say
is thank you to you and to all the fans
for for welcoming welcoming me into your
guys's family and into you know the
whole channel awesome and everything it
was just it's just such a great
experience and I never expected to be
doing anything like this so I'm so glad
for the opportunity and to have met all
you guys and and now I can watch all the
episodes without knowing what's gonna
happen yeah thanks so much wonderful
thank you so much she really is a hard
worker a great actress great talent
she's got a YouTube page she's got a
Facebook page keep showing your support
guys and catch you later
take care